omar gomes es quiropráctica tiene cuatro
hijos y a ninguno le han aplicado una
sola vacuna es parte de los padres que
deciden no vacunar a sus niños una
tendencia creciente
yo no estoy de acuerdo con la
utilización de las vacunas porque es
querer reemplazar está inmunidad natural
y los métodos naturales de poder
fortalecer nuestro cuerpo para adaptarse
de la forma lo más natural posible como
marc galia tiene sus dudas es madre de
tres y a su tercera hija decidió ya no
ponerle vacunas pues ve más riesgos que
beneficios en la mayoría de ellas me
parece que hay un problema ético y moral
tremendo en querer hacer que las vacunas
sean obligatorias puesto que hay muchos
factores a tomar en cuenta y es que el
senado mexicano aprobó reformas legales
que hacen obligatoria la vacunación si
los padres no cumplen la procuraduría de
protección de niñas niños y adolescentes
podrá tomar acciones detrás de la
iniciativa está ricardo monreal el líder
de la bancada mayoritaria de morena en
la cámara alta y este movimiento anti
vacunas
ha ido avanzando en el mundo
méxico no es la excepción
esto ha provocado que haya rebrotes
de enfermedades que creíamos ya
superadas el infectólogo alejandro
macías quien fuera a estar contra la
pandemia de influenza h1n1 en 2009
respalda la nueva ley la única
enfermedad realmente que hemos
erradicado por la paz de ícaro moyano y
software que vacunar ya ya no seamos
despreocupar de ella es la viruela ok
todas las demás en cuanto dejemos de
vacunar masivamente vamos a volver el
problema la ley aún debe ser ratificada
por los diputados una formalidad que se
espera antes de fin de año
galia omar y otros padres que comparten
sus argumentos seguirán evitando las
vacunas pues la explicación de los
médicos y la nueva legislación no los
hace cambiar de parecer